You've spoken a lot about empathy,
and it's impossible for me not to mention.
We've actually had almost
two weeks of shows,
I believe now, where
we've not once mentioned
the president of the United States
because I haven't wanted him to be a part
of the conversation.
I've wanted the conversation
to go deeper than that.
But I'll bring him up now
because we have a leader
of the country who I
think everyone would agree
has a chronic inability
to demonstrate empathy.
I feel that that has been a,
a situation like what
happened after the killing
of George Floyd is, as crazy as it sounds,
it's an opportunity for change.
It's an opportunity for the
president of the United States
to bring us all together
and to say beautiful things
that might actually bring
about lasting change.
And I feel that that has been
squandered by our president.
Yeah, so I love you for not centering him
in your conversations
'cause it's not about him.
This election coming up is
not a referendum on one guy
and one office.
It's really referendum on who we are
and who we're gonna be to each other.
And we've got to raise the
frequency in our nation
in terms of the love and empathy.
But you mentioned him,
so let me just say this.
I just fundamentally believe,
and I've watched leaders
on both sides of the aisle
demonstrate this.
You can't lead the people if
you don't love the people.
And he just does not love all Americans.
You don't have to agree
with all Americans.
But his willingness to so cavalierly deny
so many Americans human dignity,
for him to trample upon the very humanity
of other Americans to cheapen this nation
by working so hard to divide us
and to make us hate each other.
All of those things
mean he is illegitimate
in the kind of moral
leadership that we need.
He may have the trappings of power.
He may have the title of the office,
but the title doesn't make the man,
the man has to make the title.
And he has been a failure,
a failure in a moral
office that Republicans
from Lincoln to Democrats like Obama
who have led with love for their country,
with malice towards none,
with charity towards all.
He's had so much malice towards so many
and so little charity towards others.
So I just want this to be
a moral moment in America.
And I'm so proud of his
former cabinet members
and national Republicans
who are coming forward
and saying just that.
That this man is uniquely unqualified
for this moment in history.
And he has cheapened, to
me, the greatest ideal
in all of humanity,
which America has driven
in every generation
to make manifest in this world,
is that we are a nation of
love where we love one another.
He is so failed to be in the fight
to make us a more loving nation,
or as King would say, a
more beloved community.
I have so much hurt for
what he's done to people.
And I've watched it.
I've watched people.
We call some countries shithole countries.
I've seen people, immigrants come to me,
begging me to do something about it.
I've watched him degrade.
You know, I talked to a
college friend of mine
whose kid was in Lafayette
Park when he stormed in,
had people storm in with
rubber bullets and tear gas.
And the anguish that somebody would think
in this sacred Capitol where people
from the March on Washington
to Second Amendment
rights people have come for generations
to peacefully petition their government.
And he just tramples that for what?
A national security issue
because he had to urgently get someone?
Nope, to hold up a book
that he should read
that talks about humility and the meek.
I can't give him more of my energy.
I wanna give it to us.
I wanna give it to love.
I wanna give it to good
people who right now
don't understand the
urgency for them to act.
That's where I wanna give it.
He's not the center of my concern,
and I appreciate you having
a show that reflects that.
Well, you know, I have not wanted to
do Trump jokes or make
it all about Donald Trump
because ultimately, I find
him very uninteresting
and his actions sadden me.
But I'm angry.
I reserved my anger for
people that enable him.
That's what makes me angry.
And I get very angry at
people who do know better,
who are in a party that may be
in the short term benefiting
from the fact that he holds that office.
But in the long-term, I
don't know how they're gonna
be able to talk to their
kids or their grandchildren.
And so I've been very moved by,
especially the military
leadership that's come forward.
Mattis, Kelly, most recently Colin Powell,
that is something that
the Republican party
does show respect for, is
our military leadership.
And when you have these
prominent members of the military
speaking out, my heart swells with pride.
I'm very happy that
people are coming forward.
I just wish there were more.
I wish there were more
people who would step forward
and say, "You know what?
"Yes, we got some good court appointments.
"Yes, we got some stuff done
"because we had someone in the Oval office
"who would do our bidding,
but this is too much."
I wish we'd hear from more
politicians like that.
Well, we've heard throughout
history the bystander.
King talked about we have to
repent in our day and age,
not simply for the vitriolic
words and violent actions
of the bad people, but the silence
and inaction of the good people.
I think that you're right.
And I think that this, again,
is that moment in American history.
And I actually feel sorry
for the Republican party
because as a lot of his
primary opponents in 2016,
'15 and '16 said, they predicted.
Lindsey Graham, all of them predicted
that he would destroy
the Republican party.
And a lot of them have gone silent now
and are refusing to tell
the truth of the perversion,
the meanness, that he's
cavalier, and the meanness
that isn't at the heart
of a lot of Republicans.
You named some of them like Colin Powell.
And so this is ultimately a
test, and a test isn't over.
This is a president who could disrespect
the peaceful transition of
power in 150 days if you lose.
He's already trying to
de-legitimize the election.
This is a president that's capable,
has shown us that he's
capable of anything.
And so the stress test on
this nation over the next 150,
160 days are gonna be great.
And this is a defining
moment for all of us.
And in a defining moment,
you're not defined by what happens to you.
This guy's capable of anything.
You're always defined by
how you choose to respond.
I agree with you.
I'm happy for those who
have decided to respond
by not silence, but by speaking up,
by lifting their voices
to be heard by history.